[Music]
boy Jesus is really laying into that fig
tree yeah he can get a little Moody but
you know he's got a lot on him yeah it's
just one tree though
yeah but he's stressed
you know you shouldn't be worrying about
this
I'm gonna say something
I will Wilt your ass hey Jesus you know
this fig tree thing really it's not that
big a deal well it's not just about the
fig tree
right I know yeah you've got a lot on
your plate we can really just take care
of the stuff for you it's allegorical is
what I'm trying to say
right but if you if you need some figs
if you really need something we can just
go get you some we can buy you things
to go to the temple and buy you things
hold on they're selling figs at the
temple yeah we're the uh Court of the
Gentiles used to be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I know
[Music]
foreign
recovery a lot of people in the office
right now getting sick could be the
covet could be anything else because you
know not really testing when you go to
the emergency rooms anymore nope but uh
we have a lot to get to today before I
get to that look there's obviously the
story right now that's breaking we don't
have all these uh the information
regarding Ted Senator Ted Cruz's
daughter he's been on the show
um
I don't want to even have to address
this it's A Private Matter this is
someone who is not of age
but when you have people on the left
right now they're saying oh you know hey
our heart goes out to Ted Cruz and his
daughter doesn't serve this but this is
what happens when you create anti-trans
legislation you're politicizing it right
there
just shut up
I don't know that's all I want can
everyone just just shut up about it
that's all I want to say I don't want to
say anything else just don't be an
[ __ ] your whole life okay so uh what
else we have to get to today time
announce this person of the year and um
surprise it's not a surprise uh
something else we want to get to today
is
this is going to be the theme you know
I've always said this to you don't trust
the experts and by that I don't mean
don't believe that there are people who
have expertise but I mean do not simply
appeal to Authority do not defer to
experts because all of the experts got
everything wrong as it relates to
Twitter we talk about the file updates
we're talking about Wikipedia and what
they are doing it's this circular
feedback loop of authority and expertise
and everyone got the Iran morality
police story wrong except
I wasn't even here that day
except us and now journalists are
quoting us and I'm not saying that I'm
an expert please I am not and certainly
not the alternates no offense
no I didn't even know the story I just
read what was in front of me right
and then Gerald knew it yeah and then
you guys got it right I'm in the and
then the rest of the media picks it up
they're like how did we get this wrong
because you
read one paragraph down so it was tough
we'll be talking about that uh and more
but uh Gerald a is here how are you sir
I'm feeling good about myself big J
journalist over here yes there you go
big J journalist I don't know what that
means sounds like a horrible nickname
and uh you know I'm 11 fastest man on
his feet he is uh in Detroit this
weekend uh it's December 8th at Mark
Ridley's Comedy Castle Dave London how
are you sir Ahoy good how about you I'm
better are you feeling better yeah I had
an acid reflux bout oh yes I have a
Thing Called Bear it's esophagus it's
fun that doesn't sound very I don't need
to over share that's what I do what is a
bear what is Barrett's esophagus uh it's
when you spend your teen years drinking
and smoking cigarettes and then later in
life well you pay for it yeah it's just
for me it's somewhat self-inflicted yeah
that and I just come from a long line of
well acidy people so asymmetrical genes
yes yes that's the gift that keeps on
giving yes it burns it burns can you use
it offensively like a Dilophosaurus was
uh
boy I never tried but
maybe I think he just bought yourself a
segment
[Music]
dilapidate there's a bodega store owner
down the street who's been pissing me
off lately I want to see if you can
blind him
ouch
so my question to you before we get to
everything else is if you could name any
one person of the year who would you
name Person of the Year if you were Time
Magazine and you're not and neither is
time Frank Stallone
[Applause]
no one no one sings by a by a Drum Fire
as well as Frankston before we get on to
any of that uh I don't know if you know
this but a tick tocker uh now is saying
this is the culture we live in that if
you do not want to date a trans woman
and of course this is not new but this
Tick Tock to explain this tick tocker
tick tocker those words sound weird
coming out of my mouth as though it's a
thing tick tocker did I say that you did
but I hate myself you do you should this
tick tocker
is explaining to you why if you do not
want to date a trans woman you are
transphobic it all makes sense now trans
women are women so if you're
heterosexual and you're a man and you
said you wouldn't date a trans woman
because it's a preference that's just
transphobia period the majority of the
time our preferences are rooted in
something problematic it could be
biology racism transphobia the list goes
on it didn't ask why it's transphobic to
not want to date a trans woman already
starting off on the wrong foot by
referring to CIS women as regular women
then says something about trans women
not being able to carry children if
that's your sole reason for dating
someone keep that same energy for all
the women who are infertile
you know what I'm gonna give her this
one
I'm gonna give her this one if if that's
the case yes I'm tran I guess in this
case I would be transphobic if it were
wedding night and you know you you you
go to the chambers and all you know and
it's and there's a a swinging uh uh
penis and testicles I would find myself
fearful I guess that would be phobic
it's science yeah it would be strange
you know I guess when you go to the
doctor and you're like we're having
trouble conceiving right and they're
like we can't figure it out either she
is a woman technically
I don't know if the reason that uh you
can't have children is because
um you're morbidly obese but proud of it
so that's Brave or the fact that you uh
that babies don't come out of wieners I
don't know I don't know what it is we've
had a lot of anal sex but not any luck
with child I don't know how this works
I've even stood on my head it doesn't
work well it's just fine do you think
they're doing that do you think that's a
trans individual is like I'm on my
ovulation cycle
I want to find the Mormon trans or the
Catholic trans natural Family Planning
couple if you exist comment below I will
host you because that is commitment and
that is to be respected even if it's
crazy uh Stephen that's not ovulation
that's just gas yes so what was that was
she trans I don't think she was trans
right no she seemed to be a regular I
mean CIS I hope she's not trans because
then I would feel very confused well
I'll tell you what then I guess I
wouldn't be transformed
she's there's what they call the barely
passables she's what they would call the
super passibles yes I've only been
transfer non-transophobic twice I was
very drunk yes very very drunk very true
he said all of our preferences are are
are rooted in something problematic she
said they can be no they can be are you
sure she did that can we watch it again
did she say they can be rooted in
something probably you might watch it
again no of course not no no she's an
idiot trans women are women no so if
you're heterosexual and you're a man and
you said you would data trans woman
because it's a preference that's just
transphobia the majority of the time our
preferences are rooted in something
at the time our preference is the
majority of the time waffle fries is
that rooted in something problematic
well
if a trans woman is a woman then why are
you putting the word Trans in front of
it well also when they say oh you know
sex is biological and gender is social
uh male to female trans is the term that
they use MTF FTF right so the whole
thing just it's look it's all about
bearings nowadays okay
we have unless you cut them off yeah
well yeah
I don't know what to say with this like
you're we're all I guess you're
transphobic look here why isn't this
ever directed at women
hey women do you wanna if you're a
straight heterosexual woman would you
want to be uh uh intimate
with a man
sorry there's no with a vagina like
would you wouldn't you find that a
little bit weird do you think that makes
you a horrible person do you think that
that means your picture should be on a
wall next to Himmler I don't
yeah just because you're not attracted
to Chas Bono yes
Bono if Chaz Bono were a biological male
I think I can use that term yes would be
attractive to no one right that's what I
mean yes she just looks like Joey Fatone
yes exactly but it's like Guy Fieri yes
well yeah nobody wants to have sex with
Guy Fieri exactly
I mean I wouldn't say nobody either
everyone has different well people
preferences yeah sure I mean yeah right
back to the problematic see it's just an
all paths lead to problematic I just
think if your shirt has sparkly flames
on it nobody should touch you sexually
right especially if you decide to uh eat
a quail that's been soaked in rum yes or
if you wear Oakleys on the back of your
head yes yeah just no reason to touch
well I think he's trying to throw people
off yeah it's like the same reason he
has a guy fiery doll next so we can use
a carpooling that's true
that's not all he does with it hey hey
oh what's going on it looks like there's
some breaking news uh from what I'm
seeing on CNN right now
[Music]
okay well look I think you all know this
and people aren't happy about it uh
Warnock has defeated Herschel Walker
yeah in the Georgia Senate runoff uh but
in a new development appears that demon
babies are now running wild
so who could have foreseen this coming
oh man us
we saw it coming we did we tried to warn
everyone we tried to warn you no one
cared you just wouldn't listen mayor of
Amity all right well that's been uh
breaking news
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
to Georgia it will spread and the demon
baby would be everywhere it will be
World War demon baby and I will be your
president if you let me to stop a demon
I could be a pie demon baby Piper yep
that's right because everybody knows
there's another demon baby demon baby
can't resist that's one thing that's
Hershey Walker playing the demon baby
flute follow me demon baby let's follow
me to Canada
human baby page of cold your natural
habitat
all right uh we're going to be getting
some developments here regarding the
Twitter files and and unfortunately
Wikipedia should have been keeping our
eye on them a little bit more kind of
like the United States with Syria for a
while it's like oh I can't believe we
forgot about you guys now
uh time just announced it's person of
the year and if you haven't been paying
attention in case you had lost all your
faith in the media times person of the
year is this guy
[Music]
runner-up was Carrot Top so zalinski uh
joins a list of many other esteemed
bottom persons of the year uh including
the Ayatollah Khomeini Joseph Stalin
Adolf Hitler they don't all they can't
all be gems Stalin won it twice a repeat
winner yes two times wow that's nice and
not in the good years he was still
killing lots of his own people during
those times is is Time person of the
year is it like a placeholder for just a
person who has had some kind of an
impact including super negative but
giving it to Stalin twice seems like a
real misstep it is a bit of a misstep
that was you know the time when he was
alive with Hitler and then the time when
he wasn't I mean if we don't want to
read Mass Shooters manifestos because we
don't want to inspire copycats you would
think putting Stalin on the cover of
time you know might have the same effect
maybe just not the the mass genocide
people like yeah I mean kolmani the
barrier to entry is too difficult
because they figure they're safe yeah I
mean he's like I can't really make this
list I'd have to kill more than all of
the Jews on the planet right now and I
can't I can't get those numbers that's a
tall order it is it's a tall order maybe
they should just step back from that a
little bit In fairness guys it wasn't
that long ago
it's true
that's completely unfair right you don't
know what you mean oh wait yes so yes so
that brings us actually and you can
comment below again who you would like
to see as person of the year and hit the
like button because the algorithms as we
get to the Wikipedia and Twitter file
stuff we're easing into it we very well
could be removed from YouTube I think we
have Carrie Lake on tomorrow too and
yeah she's resulted in us being
suspended from YouTube so head on over
to rumble likely head on over to rumble
head on over to rumble I don't know how
many times to say it I'd love to see the
numbers change like Ed Rooney's
attendance computer
um zielinski he was given uh the title
after he beat out actually some pretty
stiff competitions I understand and that
brings us to a game which we usually
play on Mud Club but we thought it was
important because you can play along
with us it's guess the person of the
year
thank you
boy that sounds really well done it's
far too professional yeah it's far too
good yeah it really was something out of
character yeah so here's the Neil
deGrasse Tyson thing yes exactly so
here's the uh here's the theme of the
game right I'm going to read to you or
I'm going to show you a list of people
and you're supposed to guess whether or
not they were nominated for person of
the year I miss it when it was Man of
the Year yeah I I didn't take any
offense to that ladies you have to ruin
just one more thing you're saying that
Hitler wasn't person of the year no he
was definitely Man of the Year
well hey Ava Braun got him to kill
himself
trying to be politically correct while
giving it to Stalin twice
I cared quite as much back then about
that but anyway all right so we're gonna
go through this all right give me the
people and have to guess if these people
were actually nominated you can play
along with me and chat we'll start with
a person number one
Elliot Paige Elliott page yes I'm going
to say Elliott page was nominated yes
for uh person of the year I'm with you
yes Z of the Year yes yes either yes
okay and and the answer is
no no okay come on all right your strike
looks like the cover of it is Steinberg
all right next next candidate
Rupert Murdoch all right
Rupert Murdoch no no no how could that
guy be person of the year I mean he's
barely walking upright and the answer
look at that next someone needs to
Pardon himself all right give us the
answer all right the answer is
no all right
we're right okay you're doing good give
me a couple more let's let's see let's
wrap this up because I feel like I know
where this is going all right give me
the next one let's go
[Applause]
playing the piano with his dick all
right next up Kamala Harris Kamala
Harris person of the year here's the
thing if the title was
most entirely useless person of the year
she should be not and I mean that like I
some people you really dislike she is a
useless human being do you ever see her
on a panel she contributes nothing she
says nothing she understands nothing
she's barely even present she's like she
actually causes precedence she causes me
an existential crisis
well they had to get somebody more
mentally deficient than the president
they had to search far and wide Who was
the first candidate out of the primary
Kamala there's no way Kamala was
nominated for person I'm gonna say yes
because we live in this sometimes go
ahead all right and she is
okay give me the next one next one
well you know what I'm going to say yes
because they were such big fans of
Hitler and Stalin yeah I guess I'm gonna
follow your lead on that one yes all
right and the answer is
Putin Vladimir Putin this is prior to
zelinsky was person of the year and XI
Xing ping was nominated in other words
there's no reason for Putin not to be
he's equally as significant
I'm gonna say no I'm also going to say
because his enemy won right I also I'm
going to say no but uh based on uh
opposite of logic okay there we go all
right and the answer is no it was not
nominated you thought he should be
though there's one last one one last one
one last person Ron DeSantis nominated
for person of the year well actually I'm
going to say yes he was nominated
because I would have had to acknowledge
yeah I'm gonna say he's conservative so
no okay all right the answer is
oh there you go hey you know what time
wasn't all that bad okay there you go
this has been times person of the year
guessing it
thank you
all right here I want to talk about a
few things that are pretty important
when more time goes into the Stinger
than the game yes exactly
hey
I'm sorry so I think you got them all
right though yeah yeah yeah seven for
eight that's seven for eight that's
awesome so here's the theme of today
okay and it's uh not only people will
often use the term mainstream media and
this has almost become a trouble like
gleam stream media the demon Kratz look
the issue is this uh
people want you to believe and
consistently defer to experts and when
they do when they say that when they do
that what that does is well two things
first off it assumes that you cannot
become an expert in a topic right it
makes it something uh unattainable and
it also absolves you of doing your own
work as far as doing research for
yourself and so that brings us to the
theme of today we want to walk through
all of these stories that the experts
are wrong
also my headphones are wrong today all
right so it keeps going like number nine
from left ear to right here I don't know
what's happening with this I think I hit
it with my knee all right there we go so
Monday
and what happened on Monday I wasn't
here on Monday
uh we told you here though and by that I
mean Gerald and Dave that the mainstream
media Outlets like the New York Times
were misreporting that Iran disbanded
the morality police yeah uh and by the
way people on the left and on the right
reported this incorrectly and just so
you know this is one of those things
um where
we read these stories sometimes and we
see the New York Times or we see people
on the right we see these authoritative
sources covering it we're going well
it's so obvious there must be something
we missed like clearly they read the
next paragraph that we think they missed
that there must be a third or fourth
paragraph right or another speech that
was given a quote that we just don't
have because even us here sometimes
we're gaslit and go well they are
experts and then we realize oh no wait
they can't be bothered to read beyond
the title
and I can't even say that I was right
that day because I wasn't here so and I
don't mean any disrespect right but
louder with Crowder
this show the the alternates
got it right before the New York Times
that day yesterday the New York Times
reported that Iran will be abolishing
its so-called morality police comment if
you've seen this out there right now all
of the news organizations have been
covering this and we feel like they have
been covering this incorrectly for
whatever reason Muhammad javda
Montessori right where he said the
morality police was abolished by the
same authorities who installed it so
that's what they took and ran with and
basically thought okay well Iran is
taking some positive steps here and
they're going to abolish some morality
police the only problem is it's not true
right here's the actual full quote from
the Iranian attorney general the
morality police has nothing to do with
the Judiciary System the same source
that created it in the past from the
same place it has shut down of course
the Judiciary System will continue its
surveillance of social behaviors across
Society in the same
Source it kind of shown but they're
going to continue to monitor your
behavior across Society hey you guys
yeah good work yeah thank you I was just
listening to everyone else
you're about as useless as Kamala Harris
that's a logo so he's right so we put
this out there and then journalist uh an
actual journalist uh Sana uh is it Sana
ibrahimi yep some young guy so um
actually caught wind of our coverage
retweeted it saying Crowder bits YouTube
channel tonight they don't know describe
it's just a secondary YouTube channel
YouTube channel talking about the fake
news published by a very familiar name
on The New York Times and so this was
someone who report who's been reporting
on this quite a bit who knows what's
happening there and probably watched in
frustration as the New York Times And as
other sites on the right who often get
their cues from New York Times and just
rehash it with a little bit of a hat tip
and some kind of commentary there about
the lame stream media she was probably
frustrated because she didn't have
enough of a platform
thank God you guys well I wasn't on
Monday decided to be accurate because
she said I'll draft in behind in the
comments below it below Remy's tweets
are hysterical yeah they really are
because some of them are liberals so
like here's someone AKA Matthew 1
tweeted imagine how far Legacy
newspapers have strayed that Stephen
Crowder is the sensible guy in the room
for now I'll take the win where I can
get it
so frustrating this is someone who does
not like me
then Hanoi book wrote let's be fair
they're not wrong here and by they I
mean Dave Landau good shout out to you I
saw that
one person knew who the photo was of one
person uh finally said uh Matt absu
questioned uh what is so awful about him
and then there are a bunch of responses
look there's a lot that's awful about me
but I wasn't even there that day it's
not even your fault well the funny thing
is it's they're blaming the New York
Times because if the New York Times runs
this story and everybody else in the
media picks it up all of a sudden people
stop focusing on Iran quite as much in
the United States because that's a world
away we get our own problems to deal
with right oh I guess they're they're
taking steps to correct this fine uh
protests whatever that makes them lose
steam that makes this movement kind of
die out a little bit at least from
International and that means people die
exactly that means people get executed
yeah that's the part it's people are
being murdered and do you have and you
have no problem reporting that it's not
happening that's a serious issue yeah
hey you know what else too we've talked
while we're talking about this you know
Hunter Biden thing which we'll get into
a little bit it's not just about the
corruption with the big guy getting 10
right obviously that does uh that
pertains to our national security
interests the liability for former Vice
President Biden but while we're talking
about this with the Iran story people
can die yeah hey with Hunter Biden at
the very least when you know that there
were
pornographic pictures some very clearly
of people underage hey how many sex
trafficking Rings could you have busted
how many sex slaves could have been
saved yeah if the FBI decided to I don't
know pick up a laptop if the New York
Times decided to I Don't Know cover it
people say well this is ill-gotten game
okay let's assume that that's true for a
second this is something no one else is
talking about and I don't know why let's
assume that it was ill-gotten game which
it wasn't he's a dumbass who was so high
he forgot to pick up his laptop at Geek
Squad but even then were you were you
working behind the scenes if you tried
to throttle it in front of the scene
saying well these were nude pictures and
that goes against our policies did you
see the underage girls
where was it hey it's not about virtue
saying like what you do in front of the
scenes
you could stop it you could save some
women out there there are more slaves
than ever ever in recorded history on
Earth right now over 40 million that's
because a lot of them are sex trafficked
you mean to tell me that you can't find
any leads based on what Hunter Biden did
spare me the [ __ ] with your sex
trafficking Charities and you're nothing
but nets for malaria over in West
African countries you don't give a rat's
ass okay let's say you banned it on
Twitter on Facebook does anyone else you
know what comment below would anyone
else like to see our intelligence
agencies when they're given a layup
go after the sex traffickers aren't we
can we find common ground on that that
we don't want underage girls sex
trafficked or boys
do you remember how many other people
were a molested or assaulted by Dr
Nasser after the FBI had been tipped off
by several girls at Michigan State and
they were right well we'll get right on
that and I believe I'm Gone by memory
here but I think it was like substantial
30 40 50 potential additional people
right that we know about we're molested
I believe that's roughly the number that
the FBI did such a bang-up job of
getting on that story and as it relates
yeah well and you also say ill-gotten
what is the policy of the store where
you dropped off the computer as far as
Kitty porn is involved right yeah I
would imagine that they have to report
it so that would make it completely not
ill-gotten no exactly it's pretty much
take a laptop leave a laptop policy
right if it's after 60 days yes
unbelievable it really you know it
really is it's one of those things where
we sit here and we talk about as though
people want to make a difference and
then the F your intelligence agencies
rated Rudy giuliani's apartment as part
of you know a PR stunt and they avoided
Hunter's laptop like it was Adam West's
shark repellent
and you mean to tell me that there's
nothing you could do there to shut down
the worst of the worst on Earth who are
trafficking underage prostitutes hey is
anyone here doubting is anyone disputing
that Hunter Biden had processed no is
anyone disputing that there were sexual
interactions with people who were
underage 100 but no no one's disputing
any of that there's nothing you can do
that's why we got to disband the FBI and
CIA I get it I get it you guys want to
be buddies with the IRS and give them
Glocks how about you go after actual
criminals how about you go after people
who are causing irreparable harm and
destroying generations of families not
even talking not talking about the drug
war give these people the drug war man
it's just okay
do you think we shouldn't have a war
against sex trafficking
against selling women into sexual
slavery against their will sure these
are the same people who were silencing
the stories hey I wonder how many how
many gigs of a pedophile pornography of
underage pornography was found on CIA
computers remember we covered that story
quite a bit oh it's a conspiracy don't
believe you're lying eyes and ears but
with NASA it was actually 70 more geez
Oh I thought oh so just a couple just 70
more people tipped off after by the way
do we know is that guy still walking is
that guy has that guy not been executed
he's not been killed in jail and I'm not
sure why yeah well look when we get to
what is it gillane Maxwell I was
mispronounced the first name did we find
out all the people that went to the
island that were taking part in this
because we had her on trial I mean she
has the Black Books she was there she
chose the list of people we could
probably put an end to these rings from
the very top around the world with the
guest book that they had at that Island
right yeah I mean that should be coming
out soon I think just how about this how
about you just save some of the puberty
blockers that you give to all the trans
kids who you're saying are being abused
and you use that same exact chemical
which is what we used to use before to
chemically cast straight
all the pedophile rapists at Epstein's
Island how about you use it to
chemically castrate anyone involved at
any point with sex trafficking uh well
really any kind of sex trafficking but
certainly underage sex trafficking and
this is this is it brings us to Twitter
can you load a gun with the pill
yes I don't know I think you probably
I've seen guns that shoot like uh like
gumballs yeah I saw a clown he would
shoot to another clown and he'd catch it
in his mouth really yeah so my point is
sounds like heaven your imagination
is that that's the limit to the
possibilities and they really should
crack open the black book I don't
understand why there would be plea deals
and Bargains for something so disgusting
right just an opinion I mean yeah I'd
like to know who's in there because
somebody knows who's still walking
around that likes to uh have children
hey for this tree to not be lighting up
and cl like it's distracting me I keep
thinking that it's trying to like strobe
me in
you could shove it in the Michigan State
guy yeah all right what were you saying
there uh no just a little bit of silver
lining for Larry Nasser he was assaulted
in prison yes not silver lining for him
silver lining for us right oh my
goodness I hope he was assaulted with
silver
no yeah just was an expensive assault
well that's just to make sure he's not
you know he's not a pedophile werewolf I
don't know look call me old-fashioned I
think I really do think I support
execution for serial uh child sex
offenders you can comment below I agree
I mean how many hundreds of people does
it take at what point do you say yeah
this guy can't be in the camp anymore
and at what point do you say hey maybe
they're not incompetent maybe the FBI is
complicit I mean maybe they're
incompetent with underage girl number
one two three even four that's what we
call the grace underage sexual assault
for the FBI okay but when you get over
when you get over the 50s the 60s the
70s
how shitty are you at your job that you
can't stop the molestation of more girls
as girls are coming forward
how shitty are you at your job but you
can't just look into Hunter Biden's
laptop and find out who's trafficking
those kids
not saying it's some underground cabal
of people I'm saying it's out there in
the open
and the most egregious sin here's the
FBI the your intelligence agencies doing
nothing about it nothing about it but
hey hey you'll be looking into January
6th all right
sorry I had to get that out of my system
let's go into the Twitter files update
and by the way this is a live show
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern
you can watch it here you can watch it
on rumble on Mud Club we'll be playing
Steven no Sports World Cup Edition I
have not cheated I know nothing other
than the United States and Iran we're
playing in that sucker and you hate it
that's it
all right so if you're wondering uh why
they're having more of the Twitter uh
files released well uh we have some
answers so yesterday Matt TV Tybee how
do you pronounce it
Twitter Deputy uh Deputy general counsel
I think is the term another stupid made
up so Jim Baker was let go by Elon Musk
here's a tweet on Friday the first
installment of the Twitter files was
published here we expected to publish
more over the weekend many wondered why
there was a delay we can now tell you a
part of the reason why on Tuesday
Twitter Deputy general counsel and
former FBI general counsel oh there it
is the time you're batting a hundred you
pedophile enableists Jim Baker was fired
among the reasons vetting the first
batch of Twitter files without knowledge
of New Management
that's interesting so he was vetting the
files before they were released to Tybee
and Barry Weiss so a guy that used to
work at the FBI was vetting files that
likely would incriminate people at the
FBI for censoring information you
mispronounced absolutely but yes yes
sorry that's my bad it's just a
different dialect yes and so he's the
guy that was secretly vetting files
before they were sent to the reporters
and also a little key bit of information
here he's also the guy who encouraged
flagging the laptop story as hacked
material oh so the guy who clearly
screwed up at his job either because he
was incompetent or because he was
dishonest was then in charge of vetting
whether other people were incompetent or
dishonest and of course there's the FBI
connection are you starting to get the
picture when people try to say it's an
extremist view to say defund disband the
FBI no no it's not an extremist view
it's a given unless you're a [ __ ]
he wasn't incompetent he was very
competent at the job he was given he did
it very well unfortunately I was trying
to give him the benefit of the [ __ ]
doubt yes I know I know I should agree
no no I appreciate that I was I get to I
get to play good cop you get to go and
be like oh he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah I agree yeah yeah thank you I would
just saying I agree that he's an [ __ ]
yes and I agree with you that he was not
incompetent he was complicit yes oh very
much so look and if he did this stuff
right now while Elon Musk was the CEO
owner of Twitter what do you think he
was doing to information prior to that
one can only speculate correction he is
both complicit and incompetent the fact
that he was doing this wow I must have
taken it over what'd you think was gonna
happen he's a 4chan artist with a
mission to destroy you you think he
wasn't gonna find out that's how
arrogant these FBI people for the same
reason that 74 girls gymnasts get
diddled by Larry Nasser because ah you
know what No One's Gonna figure it out
well we're we're the finals say that's
all 70 more come forward yeah yeah I
mean come on we could put him on leave
until we investigate but that's paper we
can't be chasing down every 74 people
leads yeah
nobody's got that kind of time that's
half the arena football league if you
see something say something 70 times yes
just not to the FBI yeah 80's the magic
number for the FBI by the way hit the
like button if you think we need to
disband these intelligence agencies I'm
not saying that we do not need some kind
of National Intelligence but we need it
to actually be intelligent so when Baker
worked at the FBI he was by the way of
course pivotal trying to tie Trump to
Russia Gates so this again incompetent
or dishonest how do you get you think
you'd be right on some [ __ ] Accidentally
In other words you have a 50 50 shot to
say the hunter Biden laptop story is
true or it's not keep in mind at that
same time the guy from the computer shop
was saying hey hey I'll confirm it hey
I'm willing to be under oath in the FBI
was a guy you know we'll get to it
Giuliani thing I have the laptop right
here and it's you know it's it's it's
it's Hunter of course he's committing
correct it's also a picture of him
putting Eminem on the [ __ ] and you're
like we don't care
you had a 50 50 shot
probably about 100 separate occasions
with russiagate to get it right
accidentally Baker
so
he was instrumental in trying to tie
Trump to russiagate uh here we have a
quote from the New York Post when
Clinton campaign lawyer Michael Sussman
wanted to plant the bazaar false claim
of a secret Communications Channel
between the Trump campaign and the
Kremlin Baker was his go-to speed dial
contact yeah by the way also a major
role in the prosecution of Michael Flynn
Oh you mean the uh erroneous prosecution
I like that word Michael Flynn yes this
guy's a dirt bag yes absolute tart pack
that would be an insult to bags oh dirt
yes it would yes it wouldn't but this is
this is the guy that's working had his
hand in all of these things and by the
way these are examples
Russia gate
and we we say that do you remember
living through the time where it was
Donald Trump is basically bought and
paid for by Russia he's a plant he's
kind of a trojan horse in the American
Society for Vladimir Putin he's a stool
all of these sayings were coming out
with no faction did you say he's a stool
stooge
he's got a he's got a much stronger
stool than Joe Biden the best stool
I guarantee you it's more firm dual
sample he's more of a softener yes
exactly but I mean we were living
through this time where these
intelligence agencies were giving us
this information and making Donald
Trump's life a living hell because they
didn't like him they'd spied on his
campaign that was proven and then they
were saying oh he was bought and paid
for by Russia Hillary Clinton's denying
that the election results were
legitimate because Russia interfered
with the election that was all does that
not impact our country does that not
impact our president's ability to do his
job listen if he had been influenced by
Russia fine make his job a living hell
because it should be he's doing doing
something illegal I get it right but
that didn't happen these have real what
happened with Mar-A-Lago remember that
oh that's right
yeah we knew Merrick Garland was right
on the case he's just waiting for 74
more people to come forward but this
they made it look good for them right
that's all they needed yes so here's the
thing and this brings us to uh I think
with probably the most important
component of all this is uh now
Wikipedia keep in mind Wikipedia
pedia right in the name you used to have
to buy encyclopedias by yeah
door-to-door salesman wiki Wikipedia is
the biggest portal to information that
obviously some people know it's not
fully reputable but it's generally
regarded as reputable by people who
don't really know how to do proper
sourcing information that's why we make
all of our sources by the way available
at ladderwithcrediter.com Link in the
description and I the irony is not lost
on me that the next Source I'm going to
present to you the next reference is
Wikipedia but that's because it's a
story about Wikipedia so it has to
happen yes so I so just just hold your
comments before you admonish me
Wikipedia has now indicated that they
may just delete the whole article of the
Twitter files to begin with ah I see
they said initial news reports may be
unreliable and uh you know it's funny
we've often talked about Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube and Google and all
these fake news but this whole time we
really kind of haven't paid enough
attention Wikipedia has been right there
they've been there this entire time
ah
[Music]
I never saw that Yakuza is not in the
soundboard today it's okay
that was the computer not me yes
oh now here's the beauty of what happens
right you have the FBI saying Twitter's
legit
yeah the FBI saying oh Facebook's legit
oh YouTube's legit yeah the CDC saying
this information is legitimate anyone
who disagrees is illegitimate right then
you also have this with Wikipedia this
is the circular feedback loop you have
these intelligence agencies and you have
these major platforms who say that a
story they will claim that a story is
not legitimate if it cannot be verified
by what they quote unquote consider a
legitimate Outlet like AP they've never
screwed up or Reuters they've never
screwed up or New York Times they've
never screwed up and so then their
friends say well we're not going to
cover this and they say well then I
guess it doesn't exist so some of the
reasons that were given from Wikipedia
and there's some interesting twists here
they let anybody edit it well not this
one they have super editors right but
still it's
so this is these are some of the reasons
the editors are giving uh Ray West 92
one of the editors wrote what an effing
nothing Burger an embarrassment for
taibi to think Twitter taking down
revenge porn was a political Scandal but
it doesn't need a standalone article uh
then this was generally ignored by the
media with good reason talking about of
course Twitter's silencing of the hunter
Biden laptop story
was ignored by the media with good
reason and thus failed to establish
notability another editor wrote many
news networks avoided covering this as
there is no there there for instance the
New York Times as of now has published
nothing on this so because the New York
Times didn't publish anything on it and
because the other mainstream Outlets
didn't publish anything on it
they claimed that then it must not be
legitimate but the reason that they're
not covering it is because it's
so it's all the same [ __ ]
yes yes exactly yeah the New York Times
didn't cover it therefore it's not true
and the New York Times says well how do
we know if it's true and they say I
don't know we were waiting for you and
they said well we're waiting for you I
guess let's just not cover it no they
were basically just saying because the
New York Times chose not to cover it
because they don't like how it Paints
the political party that they support
the most we will use that as cover and
say well it's not a real story right so
those things were given as reasons why
this story not that it shouldn't have
prominence not that it shouldn't be
promoted that it shouldn't exist and you
know why New York Times didn't cover it
you know why New York Times didn't cover
it because it's part of a fake story
about the Iran yeah that's another one
they're busy also because Twitter and
Facebook right they labeled it as
potentially misleading information why
because former FBI official Jim Baker
was working there saying oh yeah no this
isn't real
this is the people who avoided the
people who managed to miss Larry Nassar
sexually assaulted 70 73 young girls
70-something young girls it's hard for
me to keep track of time over 70 people
right the same FBI they had officials
there the and by but by that I mean our
brightest and best uh working at Twitter
saying this is this is not legitimate
this should be throttle so the New York
Times said oh okay there's no story
there that's what all these major press
Outlets said and then Wikipedia says
well since these major press Outlets
didn't cover it must not be legitimate
right and and then they're saying oh
it's revenge porn it's like oh okay I'm
sorry we we've talked about this uh did
James Wood post uh uh or James Woods did
he did he post a uh a penis picture is
that what he got removed from Twitter
for no no I don't think that's what it
was was the other guy that we covered
the other day who was kind of anti-china
we found that out like anti-chino
Chinese Communist party is he is that
what he posted as well was it just
pictures of Hunter Biden's penis that we
were all concerned about no it was a
much bigger story than that these are
the people that are controlling with
information that other Wikipedia users
get to see and they're saying it's
nothing there because I don't want
anything to be there and I'm going to
focus on one little piece of this and by
the way it wasn't just them that same
verbiage was used by almost everybody I
saw trying to discredit this on Twitter
and I'm talking about all of our
favorite Bad actors on Twitter coming
out and saying that there was nothing
there they were using the exact same
information and by the way Toby got
attacked by all these same people Tabby
has he's a journalist he's an absolutely
Bonafide got to and to God journalist
there's some still out there and he's
being accused of being the pr person for
the richest person on the world again
really strange how every single one of
these accounts uses that exact same
phrasing it's like these exact same
language come up with a crap story
because they don't like no you're
absolutely right it's the exact same
language and this is where when people
say oh it's a private company they can
do whatever they want shut up dummy shut
up you [ __ ] really you mean to say hold
on a second you mean to say it's a
private it's a private platform they can
do whatever they want it's not the
government censoring anyone hold on a
second do you mean to say that when
practicing doctors clinicians are
removed D platform from Facebook Twitter
Youtube Google giving medical
information based on what they've
observed in their practice and clinical
data because of the commands from the
top down coming from the highest paid
longest standing unelected official in
our government Anthony fauci that it's a
private platform you mean to say that
when the the actual state of your
constitutional republic hangs in the
balance
because of object because of the death
of objective journalism why because the
FBI intelligence agencies and people who
are the figureheads the de facto leaders
of the Democratic National Committee
telling every single major Tech platform
that they need to remove you and punt a
story that that's a private platform and
that's not even to get into the argument
that these private platforms enjoy the
luxury of being treated as a public
utility so they have reduced legal
liability
if I say something deliberately
defamatory I'm liable for it Twitter
isn't Facebook isn't YouTube isn't why
because they're treated as utilities so
not even getting into that they are
doing the work directly of the
government fauci says get rid of that
doctor yeah YouTube says okay and
Facebook says okay and then you say
private company they can do whatever
they want what part of that is a private
company FBI says you can't cover that
which turns out to be true by the way in
Facebook Twitter Youtube Google alphabet
they all say oh okay you can't cover
that what part of that is a private
company enforcing their own policies
stop being dumb yeah and by the way just
for all the people out there with
parents right now this just happened I
think just the other day
the I think Pfizer is getting another
emergency authorization for their fifth
booster right cool four hold on sorry
for kids for kids under five years of
age I just you know if I'm a parent out
there and I'm worried about anything
like this I'm looking for information on
every single thing that goes into my
kids body including medicine that I'm
giving them just for whatever they're
feeling bad right as a parent you're
trying to take care of your child these
information platforms these people are
basically saying no you can't have the
opposing view out there you can't have
people say that maybe there's some
concerns at all and I'm being careful
because I'm on YouTube We're on one of
the very platforms that will remove you
for saying information that's widely
available from the CDC in California
which I quoted and got this show banned
do you realize every single instance uh
in the last year have heart attacks guys
every single instance in the last year
and a half that we've been suspended
later we have been 100 verifiably
correct yes things that you can say now
yeah but when we said it you weren't
allowed to say it even though by the way
the data didn't change the information
didn't change what was permissible is
what changed you saying that the flu the
standard flu on a year-to-year basis is
more lethal to Children four out of the
last 10 years according to the city
according to the CDC saying that more
deadly for children 19 and under the flu
yeah you can say that now because now
they've come out I said it I feel
awkward saying I know you still feel
awkward saying trouble for example us
saying the hunter Biden laptop story
when Giuliani showed the laptop that was
another reason why we were suspended uh
the other one Carrie Lake saying hey you
know what we don't have the best systems
in place for the elections in Arizona
with the primary that she won do you
realize that every single instance of us
being removed this last year suspended
on YouTube you can now say because it
was verifiably correct they didn't do
their due diligence it was just
inconvenient by the way Elon and weighed
in saying uh most of the he was saying
most of the earth meaning what most
people think uh the mainstream media is
biased and Wikipedia uh basically cites
mainstream media sources to confirm this
claim Wikipedia has a non-trivial
left-wing bias here's the thing that's
so true all of this is this is why I
said the experts are wrong this is an
intellectual fallacy that you will learn
about very very early on in University
if they're teaching you critical
thinking okay so let's go to
it's a logical fallacy alert time right
now I hope that you guys paying
attention it's the appeal to Authority
okay let me read this for you it's
insisting that a claim is true simply
because a valid Authority or expert on
the issue said it was true without any
other supporting evidence offered
that pretty much can describe any of
these stories
that's a good point
all of them in fact so yes every one of
them let me give you some other examples
of stories that didn't happen the
Twitter public private side right the
Twitter files didn't happen according to
Wikipedia or most likely didn't happen
what else didn't happen the 100 laptop
obviously didn't happen we've already
touched on that right A lot of people
didn't see it happening right yeah no
one's my way of proving it hey you know
what else didn't happen hmm
some of you thought that there were
violent riots right billions of dollars
in Damages that thousands of Officer
casualties no no those didn't happen
because legitimate news outlets right
the authority what no no you you're
misremembering the mostly peaceful
protests what you're seeing behind me is
one of multiple locations that have been
burning in Kenosha Wisconsin over the
course of the night a second night since
Jacob Blake fiery but mostly peaceful
Times by a police officer
exist in the same sentence what's so
funny though is that isn't even a little
peaceful yeah it's just Armageddon
behind him and he's like it's mostly
peaceful it's not like a hobo a round of
fire in a 55 gallon drops yeah it looks
like the future in Terminator too but
it's mostly peaceful and by the way your
producer hates you he sent you out with
a paintball mask and a tank top and yeah
and pink headphones yes yeah Burning Man
is more peaceful yeah that is in the
back of your shirt that says please kick
my ass and take take my stuff oh
I said someone there
you know what else didn't happen
Whitmer didn't send young people with
covet into Old Folks homes right
Governor Whitmer didn't do that we had a
protest that involved thousands of
people on the capitol lawn in Michigan
they said hundreds I was about to say
that didn't happen either that was only
well then later they said thousands when
they tried to tie me to the kidnapping
plot which also was not a real plot of
Governor Whitmer well you'll take the
number increase yes because at least
attack take the winds and there was
never anybody that were people that were
in gangs beating the crap out of the
elderly that had coveted that never
happened of course
according to the FBI yes the most
trusted name in intelligence
Governor kidnapping yes
it was only uh 21 out of the 22 where
FBI agents this is real and by the way
the the Wikipedia editors who of course
are very left-leaning they've been
deleting and censoring truths they don't
like for a very very long time so
remember in 2021 we talked about this uh
they nominated the topic mass killings
under communist regimes for deletion
five times wow five times and by the way
we did our own video back then where we
posted truth on Wikipedia verifiable
truth with sources to see if it would be
taken down we ran our own experiment
wherever you line up
you need to include these points of view
and you certainly need to include
arguments made on the legal record
and with medical substantiation what we
added uh was what should have happened
as a result of a failure to comply now
this isn't my opinion
or 500 edit uh Wikipedia administrator
consensus opinion this is the law what
happens if you do not comply with a
subpoena let me read you
the law according to the Arizona statute
41-1153 Disobedience of subpoena as
legislative contempt now that's the law
what did Wikipedia say to this Edition
the only addition that would actually
have legal standing by the way uh they
took it down saying it might be true but
no secondary source
wow Square bear caught this here's let's
let's show that clip again uh show
overlay five one of those names in that
clip is familiar right soy black soy
Bangla I don't know how to pronounce it
and I don't care soy Bangla that's the
same editor
arguing to delete the Twitter files page
right now wow right now bring up collage
F that's right now it's the same person
it's the person right there who had
truth removed is now saying we should
get rid of the Twitter files
on freaking belief I think that might
have been uh yeah I had to bring it in
same person
same person so here's you look this is
you might be biased you need a secondary
source for the law yes yes how do they
handle the Constitution well that's just
not I don't know I mean is it did
anybody else say all men are created
equal don't see it elsewhere what about
all the signers
here's a picture of the parchment ah you
could just take some Modern printing
paper put it in uh put it in tea stain
it I know that old trick National
Treasure come on come on a lot I've seen
it a lot you think I'm gonna be fooled
by John Voight's coaster nap
I said now okay either way I feel like
Jon Voight is taking a nap right now yes
well he takes a lot of money so here's
the result they blame they blame you for
being radicalized they blame you for not
trusting your institutions and by the
way if you don't trust your institutions
share this show right now because an
institution that exists is YouTube
alphabet Google let me ask you this
you're radical
and the reason that you are considered
to be radical is because like today you
probably get pissed off
you probably get pissed off because many
of you out there feel or know I don't
want to use the word feel you know that
you're unheard
and so you shout right sometimes this
has been an expression that's been used
men have to shout to be heard often in
relationships that's why you often see
men you know rage is a masking of
emotion because they don't necessarily
know how to deal with pain or they don't
necessarily feel that they're being
listened to it's true so you are angry
and I know you're very angry man Dave we
all are here
but you're angry you're blamed for being
angry okay
you're an extremist right why are you an
extremist because you're saying that you
don't trust anything well hold on a
second
Twitter Facebook YouTube Google
in tandem with the FBI remove stories
that you knew were verifiably false and
would have altered the course
of this country for the remainder of its
history they all removed these stories
stories by the way that sometimes your
experience let me give you a very
specific scenario let's say that you're
a man
okay let's say that you're a man who I
don't know
um owns a lap owns a computer repair
shop
or you own the store next to the
computer repair shop where Hunter Biden
drops off a laptop you see what's on the
laptop
you see that it's made available to
authorities you see that the authorities
say that they have no interest in said
laptop and then you see all of the media
suppress the story about the laptop all
the while around this point in time
generally speaking your store is being
burned To The Ground by mostly peaceful
protesters and you reach out to people
in positions of authority people in the
intelligence Community people in Media
or certainly trying to express your
express your experiences be it through
videographic evidence
or sworn affidavits
on big Tech platforms and that too is
removed so you've been ignored by all
the mainstream Outlets who the big Tech
platforms rely upon for verification
you've been ignored or suppressed
completely removed by all the big Tech
platforms and you know that they are
working alongside intelligence agencies
who have a vested interest in one
political party achieving complete
absolute unfettered power where do you
go where do you go and then you get
called an extremist because you've you
because you yell a little bit because
you tend to be a little bit pissed off
let me ask genuinely people out there if
you're on the left where the [ __ ] do
these people go huh
my star was burned down hey this is
happening right now hey there's a riot
in the corner of uh there's a rat in the
corner of fifth in in Oak removed
hey look I got this i got this uh
underage sex traffic removed hey my
daughter was raped
my daughter was raped by someone
involved
with the Olympic Training Center
my daughter was raped by her coach nah
FPS says we'll look into it
and that happened 72 70 however many
more times over 70.
you're a parent
where do you go
you're a person whose life is destroyed
where do you go you're a Doctor Who's
removed because fauci has a stick up his
ass where do you go you're a parent
whose child could be raped maybe you're
a parent of a child who's being sex
trafficked
hey that might be relevant certainly if
you have evidence of people in positions
of government Authority or relatives of
people in positions of government
Authority
engaging in sex trafficking hey you know
what where do you go you're just an
extremist the level of gaslighting is
not only clinical and I don't just mean
it as far as gas lighting we're not
friends anymore I mean you're being
gaslit to a degree that in a very in a
very tangible way pretty quantifiable
way leads to the deaths
of people speaking out for freedom in
Iran
it leads to girls being silenced whether
it's being raped fondled sexually
assaulted by a coach
or being trafficked to Epstein island or
to Hunter Biden's penthouse
and then you have no idea where to go
and they want you to believe that you're
an extremist near alone hey guess what
you're not you're not
there's a reason that this show is a
size that it is there's a reason when we
go and do these live shows uh many many
thousands You Are Not Alone believe me
you are actually a far bigger portion of
this country than they want you to
believe and that's why they are working
absolutely overtime to try and remove
verifiable truths
if you know what we do I I don't want to
Pedal in conspiracy theories and even if
I'm wrong I make everything as
transparent as I possibly can I provide
all the references every single day
make mistakes absolutely
and I'm not saying that you shouldn't
just to be clear I'm not saying that you
shouldn't trust people with expertise
what I'm saying
is that you need to aggregate
information
from by the way both experts
and the Layman and the peasant
I I cannot tell you how many times in my
life growing up I learned something from
somebody
who I never would have even imagined
could have taught me whatever level of
insight it was that I had a mechanic one
time
didn't have any teeth
I never leave it this guy taught not not
about cars this guy actually taught me
about the way some of these uh some of
these uh the DMVs would work or the
certification for these you know these
toll tags and he gave me some inside not
inside information he gave me
information that I didn't know he also
talked about family I remember sitting
there going wow you really can learn
something from anyone not saying you
just rely on a toothless mechanic you
told him about uh gingivitis I did and
then I told him I want a tune-up change
those spark plugs yes stop trying to wax
poetic they're a toothless mechanic man
I'm like wow you can talk really good
for not having any teeth there's no this
at all you want to tell me you like
candy yes well he did meth now he likes
straws
but Fouch sure include fouchy maybe
include the doctors who've also seen
thousands of patients
only one side says only trust fauci I'm
saying take into account what fauci said
the CDC The Who and and
acknowledge Taiwan is a place that
actually exists and acknowledge doctors
who are actually uh you know actually
practicing doctors right now who are
seeing patients and look at the data
that's available internationally
I'm saying hey you know what yeah sure
of course New York Times we use them as
a reference sometimes mainly because we
know that if we use a right-wing
reference you will simply accuse us of
bias and I understand that so we'll use
New York Times we'll use Washington Post
and we'll say by the way we were able to
verify it with this other resource and
sometimes the more reliable resource is
not the expert well the experts run
Twitter at least they did the experts
run Facebook the experts were in the New
York Times the experts run Wikipedia and
the experts run the FBI CIA
and the NSA and the IRS
I don't even want to ask
is that a group that you trust with
information
think of that group that I just told you
let's just let's put a face system Bezos
cook uh Zuckerberg Baker
whoever else with the CIA Comey
Dorsey
Nasser
not only do you trust them
there's a real question I want you to
answer below there's no hyperbole here
do you trust them with relaying to you
accurate information no my question is
would you even trust those people alone
in a room with your children
those are the experts
why are you an extremist guess what
if you're seeking truth you're an
extremist by default uh and uh by the
way from what's going on here um I think
I hear some what's that something going
on outside yeah oh is it they're doing
their office gift exchange yeah it's the
annual gift exchange yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get a manscaped lawnmower 4.0 for her
This Christmas by visiting manscapes.com
Crowder to receive 20 off and free
shipping
you really should take care of that
[Music]
right now I'm
hurry hurry Bring It Up Bring It Up full
screen full screen oh you made mistakes
justice department report outlines
mistakes leading to the beating death of
Whitey Bulger yeah
whoopsie yeah trust the institutions
guys well I think Whitey Bulger was
already kind of connected to the FBI
anyway sure he was for sure it's just a
whole hilarious headline mistakes
leading to the beating death
so uh I've been arresting him at 80.
there's not a mundane detail Michael so
you guys beat him to death right there
were so many missteps there
did you keep him in isolation well no no
did you put him in general population
yeah did you out him as like an
undercover an arc yeah yeah yeah you see
do you see where you do you see where
you're wrong everybody he was Whitey
Bulger we did we did yeah oh and then
you let him shower with the public
I see I do see your point yeah yeah just
to your point you know that's going to
be a three-star rating not a five this
year I'm sorry I see what we did here
you think we shouldn't have let the
other gang members know who he was well
it's just a risk you don't need to take
huh swinging a miss that yeah I'm a
dumbass sort of like which also by the
way reminds me you don't need to be
doing Judo by the fireplace you could
just move to the middle of the room ah
oh I understand yeah well why take the
risk there's plenty of space over there
you're less warm though just don't tell
them who he is
thank you
God you have the witness uh he was
beaten to death when really I like right
after we arrested him basically yeah it
was weird I don't know it was uh hold on
a second it was somewhere after I yelled
through the bullhorn but before I'm
pretty sure it was after the bull what
did you yell into the bullhorn that's
Whitey Bulger there goes Whitey Bulger
get him but we did have a team look this
up he did die after the beating yeah yes
so yeah and if it helps matters at all I
mean great deal of time yes yes yes can
we have Mission Control look up these
circumstances related to this for muck
Club kind of funny to see he was old I
mean he probably died before the beating
was over well yeah yeah that's fair we
believe that he died mid-beating which
is what we call uh Apex beating yes
because it's the perfect time because
it's you know it's not as long and drawn
out as it could be but you still have
enough time to think about what you've
done it's a split the difference yeah
it's the the last James Bond installment
perfect time to die it is the Goldilocks
of dying mid-beating yes it's a science
step now if you excuse me my daughter
has an appointment with a doctor to be a
gymnast yes
I don't have much time to talk about
this I'm busy investigating parents who
don't want chicks with dicks and
five-year-old girls changing rooms I
look weird look I can't save the whole
world but I will say monsters are real
yes
they live amongst us yeah
this guy
FBI
[Laughter]
oh by the way by the way we also want to
give the IRS guns yeah just yeah that's
our new proposal that's how we think we
can fix all of this and more people lots
and lots more people more people more
guns more power bore Authority and you
know what really like I just think we
should do away with uh you know the
people who aren't us hey and by the way
Eddie vulture was hiding from
authorities so he didn't die the guy hid
for like 25 years
sorry at least 10 50 oh sorry it's just
so far think about it Dave come on yeah
yeah that's what happened you can't it's
like it's just hilarious though I mean
it's I mean well yeah it's hilarious
I'll stick and guess what no one else is
going to uh no one else is going to ever
assist the authorities it's like no no
don't worry we'll take care of you yeah
sure you will sure it sure did is
witness protection still a thing yeah
his brother was a a senator or a
congressman as well like it's it's
pretty amazing hey have we heard
everything about the Paul the Pelosi
Story by the way oh yeah all the details
have come out of all oh all of it yeah
it was uh the uh a guy hey
the Vegas
uh well not all no okay and you saw that
that one went away pretty quickly
unrelated but the reporter that was
actually pushing back on all of that was
killed I think within the last six
months and weird
unrelated right yeah your conspiracy
theorists you should be dismissed out of
hand because Wikipedia says you're not a
real journalist so stop connecting dots
we have dots and that's it I don't
really need to connect dots like with
Larry Nasser it's like I don't really
need to connect dots so much as just a
lineup of 70 plus women who said they
were sexually assaulted by him after the
FBI was informed about it that's just
the after count yeah it's not the total
330 total 330.
are you serious
300 and 30.
wow
well
I mean that's
that's the human rape equivalent of Don
King stealing a hundred million dollars
from Mike Tyson where you're like ha
okay you think you'd notice it at about
20 million somehow it got to a hundred
million you'd be like okay some of that
right at a certain point you'd think
you'd know how did the FBI not notice
after
10 50 100 200 I'm trying to go Price Is
Right without going over and I can't
lose you can't no
all right the Cosby blush yeah for
crying well he was working with him by
the way uh that's by the way not true
don't fact check that it's completely
made up and it's completely outside of
the realm of possibility it's absurd
right none of us would I don't have to
state that because you might actually
believe it
so you went with 230 reports and that
wasn't good enough that's what that
means yeah potentially I don't know that
230 came forward but after all of this
stuff how many do you need 300. like I
just I just yeah we've had three we've
had three people come forward and say
some Shenanigans are going on so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
your parking pass and your building
access and we're just going to put that
on pause for a minute until we can
investigate this situation not even that
yeah I mean you don't have to arrest the
guy and haul him off at a Paddy Wagon
all you have to do is say no more
hanging out with chicks and giving them
unnecessary internal massages yeah in
front of their parents in some cases how
about we just pause that for a minute
how about you put them in the fauci's
Beagle flea helmet at least like just
for starters just to just to hold them
off till the trial yeah please give them
a flea make him uncomfortable yeah
yeah we have oh for sure oh yeah we have
hundreds of reports well call me when
you get thousands and then maybe we'll
think about it what's the opposite of
hospice care where you try and out do
hell as a precursor oh boy I mean when
you make it completely uncomfortable
that's why I feel like if you don't want
to have cruel and unusual punishment we
should we should at least make a deal
with another country where we're like
well I guess we're gonna have to
sentence you to life right in Mexico yes
yes I think it's a gulag no no no no no
no no this is this is like Escape From
LA right this is exactly like that you
just sent somebody to it hold on a
second hold on a second you got it CNN
CNN right now this is what the Intel by
the way the intelligence communities who
are Paramount January 6th committee
chair confirms criminal referrals will
happen oh good today on CNN they were
still saying that officers were killed
by the way yeah this morning they were
still talking about officers being
killed that's where your intelligence
committees your intelligence agencies
are doing their work and of course we'll
have Liz Cheney and Mitt Romney people
are going to say we absolutely need to
respect our intelligence agencies
they're the true heroes no oh no they're
not sorry they're absolutely not and for
the safety that they figured out that a
gangster getting beaten to death under
their watch a decade ago may have been a
misstep
there's no separation between big Tech
and the intelligence agencies that's
that's the problem why is this life you
know what a judge should do when he sees
these criminal Furs be like yeah
what what
the yeah what is this you just figured
this out crime there's no crime here you
guys just had political theater for
months well no the good thing is they
have all of our intelligence agencies uh
investigating the criminal trespassing
good yeah as opposed to the sexual
assault and or rape of over
300 underage girls good to see the FBI
has their priorities in check same thing
with the CIA and good to see that they
are the most trusted name in fact
checking for Twitter Facebook and
YouTube hey do you feel free shut up
with the private company can do whatever
they want any Republican who comes out
you know what I'm not there's the whole
back the blue thing which I've never
been on board with I have said that
generally speaking local police
departments obviously are required
they're necessary there are a lot of
good cops out there and they have some
tough jobs to do we're talking about
cops on the beat with guns that being
said unless we see enough people and
this includes both local police
and National Intelligence walking out
speaking out and making their voices
heard never going to Riot of course
never going to burn anything down I'll
be pretty damn anti-authority pretty
damn anti-cop how about that peacefully
but if I see one more video of you
shutting down someone's business
whenever the next pandemic hits and not
enough police step forward and say this
is wrong guess what you've now made
you've now made my enemy list
hey FBI come on CIA
all of you
I'm not on board with the black lives
matter where they're targeting your
families of course and they're being but
I'm saying peacefully I will fight you
every end because you know what I think
we kind of all want the same things
right you have these people
these people I mean people the black
lives matter activists right the people
who are embezzling millions of dollars
and you have antifa listen defund the
police and by the way the people who are
hurt are those communities but are kind
of coming full circles and defund the
police we should be regulating our own
communities hey you know what I'll make
that deal with you okay if the police
are going to come in and shut down
businesses if the police are not
actually going to put pedophiles in
prison guess what let's regulate our own
communities and thank God we have the
Second Amendment I would love a little
more self-regulation as it relates to
that
if that's the alternative to the police
making criminals out of law-abiding
citizens
and letting criminals get off scot-free
by the way to end this on a more
positive note we are going to go play of
course Stephen no sports but we uh
reached out to some of you about giving
gifts this Christmas uh for the Crowder
gives back uh segments you know we did
this last year with uh we provided some
families with their children's Christmas
wish list but we also can provide food
um here's one thing check your inbox
check your junk inbox and reply back
because we have people reach out and we
replied we replied saying yeah yeah
we'll give you all the stuff that you
want
and then you disappeared
where are you
I am just waiting to give you my money
are you man enough to take it are you
man enough to take it
candy canes are for closers
YouTube piss off